hi I'm RIA today I have one of my best
friend copy copy do not introduce
yourself a little bit sure well my name
is copy and as you can see I'm a I'm
also world-famous advice giver over on
Instagram so me and a copy have been a
friend quite a bit over time but it's a
bit difficult to make a friend when you
become an owl oh it's so hard being an
adult can be very lonely I mean I love
hanging out with my tat but it'd be nice
to have another pastry to connect with
on a more serious level so I have an
idea I'm sure that's enough and yeah
it's alright so I'm going to make you a
friend today so copy today I'm making
you wonder my favourite Japanese dessert
I'm not gonna tell you yes
so first I want to scoop ice cream do
you have any favourite ice cream flavour
a copy well I see that's strawberry so
that's definitely one of my favorites
coz it's pink
just like me I knew it that's why I
chose strawberry I love so many
different flavors though I don't even
think there's a flavor that I don't like
um except pistachio I don't want to talk
about why so full this dessert you can
use any kind of ice cream flavor
I chose strawberry because I thought you
liked being that you can make matcha
you can make chocolate anything you want
I'm going to put in the freezer until I
use it next first I'm going to use
sriracha mokou we cheat sound glutinous
flour 200 grams putting in the pot
hundred grams of Japanese sugar Japanese
sugar is a little bit finer than a
regular sugar I like it because it's
melts faster a couple blotter
turn the heat medium give a nice
cook it until it's become very sticky so
copy we met in Japan right yes we did
yeah you I exchange student do you keep
in touch with other Japanese friend of
your made in Japan I do I still keep in
touch with dango we send each other
funny baking memes almost every day
puppy do you cook a lot of home I do a
little but I have to admit I am really
guilty of ordering a lot of takeout
that's totally fine when you become
adult there's a lot of thing you have to
take care of you don't always have time
to cook right yeah it can be really hard
look at this dog oh my gosh
it's so sticky I'm going to transfer to
the slavs office and I'm going to say
this is height so next step I'm going to
use cornstarch and sprinkle on the
surface these mochi so copy what do you
think make a good friend what kind of
friend do you want to have I'd really
love a friend who's super sweet squishy
super sweet like you I think I want to
have a friend who has a same sense of
humor you know for sure someone who
totally gets you yeah exactly have you
had a difficult time to make a friend
who doesn't speak same language as you
well lucky for me I happen to be
absolutely fluent in the language of
friendship that's a really nice thing I
was an exchange student and I had a
difficult time too long English I'm
still having a struggle but I feel like
having a patient and friend it's also
important they can you know trying to
understand you and I feel like that
makes great friendship - oh absolutely
a real friend will really take the time
to get to know you even if there are
difficulties within your language
barriers okay so now I'm carding
gee mochi is very sticky so make sure to
put a lot of coal starch underneath it
so it doesn't stick and they think
that's sticky it's like spatula or like
I'm using even spoon just take it out
so we how do you go about making friends
as an adult I feel like nowadays I make
friends I walk place yeah but you can
find so many great people at work mm-hmm
look at us we ended up walking a sim
company no I'm so glad BuzzFeed is an
equal opportunity employer for pastries
when I moved to New York I don't have a
lot of friends but you know like I have
a little group of a friend and if they
invite me party and if you make good
food they remember you so I start
bringing my homemade food to a party so
cooking it's a way of a communication
for me and to make friends that's so
great and I for one know that eating
delicious food is another great way of
making friends that's true they food to
bring us together it does mm-hmm all
right
okay so let's leave the fun part you're
gonna just wrap mochi ice cream kind of
toys and mochi it's very sticky so if
you kind of pinch it it will close by
self it's like a little duckling yes
exactly
copy do you have any good advice for
keeping a friendship for a long time my
best advice I think is just to always
communicate with your friend and come to
understand these with them realize that
sometimes they'll need their own space
and other times they'll need you to be
there for them you have a good out of
ice size of you out of a tight thank you
this is almost ready but it's still a
little bit soft so I'm going to put in
the freezer about 15 minutes
here you go copy here's your new friend
mochi she's smooth on the outside she's
very sweet inside and she's a little bit
sticky so you guys gonna be a friend
forever
we'll stick together do you want to
paste it don't worry I'll explain
everything to you by calf and emoji I
hope to see you soon thank you so much
thank you so much for watching tell me
what kind of friend I should make happy
next time
[Music]